[Aplausos]
muy buenos días Pues todavía celebración
y de hecho ya hemos visto aquí por estas
calles en la zona donde nos encontramos
aquí en doja en hoteles ya están
poniendo banderas grandísimas tanto de
Francia como de Argentina muchísimas
celebración celebración también que tuvo
el presidente Manuel presente en ese
partido en la noche de ayer en el
estadio celebró con los jugadores de
Francia quienes abrazó también pudo
hablar con jugadores de Marruecos el
presidente lo han criticado mucho por
estar aquí pero él les dijo ya en Rusia
yo había hecho Exactamente lo mismo
había venido a apoyar al equipo La idea
es de compartir y de disfrutar este
momento dijo que esta copa del mundo no
tenía mayores problemas de organización
Qatar había ahí anotado pues muy buenos
puntos tampoco problemas de seguridad y
que todos esos temas otros que quedan
por resolver haciendo pues una Clara
alusión a los temas en cuanto a derecho
laboral en cuanto a derechos humanos
pues esas son cosas que pueden irse
hablando poco a poco y que finalmente el
fútbol puede ser ese tema ese eso
Federal a los países cuando no logran
finalmente hablarse políticamente En
todo caso él de esta manera pues ha
tratado de despejar todas las críticas
que se le han hecho de viajar en este
momento aquí sobre todo por parte de la
izquierda francesa